we have some other stuff to get into uh
can you stop yelling i didn't even know
mike have you seen this woman punch
herself during a speech
no but i'd like to okay so i don't know
what this is
this is one of those i think healing
conventions where they do crystals and
[ __ ] like that
okay so they punch themselves it's only
a minute long but it's worth watching
[Music]
amends which is some sort of indian
thing i guess
if i place your hand under an aesthetics
your brain will actually feel the
scratching
you will actually feel it just think
about the violence
being produced every day everything you
watch
but why do you feel it just hold on
just think about the violence being
produced every day
everything you watch
why for getting back up awkwardly
it makes you watching that
part of it it makes you more susceptible
to violence
all right i'm gonna ask this right sure
bat [ __ ] crazy
she has to be insane would you though
yeah
yeah yeah she has kind of a deanna troy
vibe to her place of harmony it would be
scary though of course very very ed
on edge the whole time why being
produced every day everything you watch
because of that
and now i will tell the police that you
hit me what a good
i gotta give it to her good pratfall
though everything good pratfall and a
good actually you know what i gotta be
honest with you
um i think arn anderson would be very
proud of those worked punches
yeah that was good i'll be honest with
you it was very impressive
part of it it makes you more susceptible
to violence
i want to live in a place of harmony
they will stand there
and keep their arm stretched out no
matter what the difficulties are and say
i want peace because i need it not
because of you
she looks like the chick from the hot
shots movies
yes sounds like her good call yes
that's what she looks like yes the
italian brother yeah yeah
i wanted you want to cook an egg on her
stomach
such a great movie and then she just
stands there and they go i guess
we need a clap
[Applause]
so
i i like her though
i asked she's um i asked some of our
listeners she's
she's different i asked some of our
listeners to do a couple things for us
now she would be we'd probably be
ripping into her even more but she's
attractive which kind of [ __ ] it right
yeah yeah of course
like if this was like some fat girl with
a septum piercing it's like
a patriarchy and then punch yourself
we'd all be left well we do have this
your brain will actually feel the
scratching
you will actually feel it so just think
about the violence
being produced every day everything you
watch
[Music]
okay that's very funny that's from eight
that's that's for the agey luck
to give him credit that's from aj good
work bro
um i always love a good wasted clip it
never gets old
that's a bit that never gets old and
this one is from mr bali songs just
think about the violence
being produced every day everything you
jack
white jacks i think we all know why
jacks
it's just so random level characters
everyday
everything you want and i love that it's
the
i like that it's the old sega genesis
it's the clearly the sega genesis which
still has like the
oh god i miss old video games that's mr
baldi's song
so subscribe to age you like and
subscribe to mr bali song that was
[ __ ] fantastic
this is your body song in the chat we
all know why i picked jack's
that's funny that's fair uh
yeah you're right if she was if she
wasn't attractive um
at least wasn't if she if she was oh i
said
i thought you went man you're right she
was she wasn't attractive yeah she would
be so much funnier but
there's just something where you're like
like again there's certain like levels
there's degrees of what guys will put up
with and with that you're like i don't
see the problem
right like any other chick you'd go what
a whack job
but when they're like italian and look
like the trick from hotshots you're like
yeah whatever you're right somebody
someone needs to do the randy orton rko
with it that would be great